hey 42 here the Aztecs sacrificed one
percent of their population every year
of about 250,000 people they also
sacrificed Eagles Jaguars butterflies
and hummingbirds welcome to RIF William
Herschel Discoverer of uranus lived to
be 80 for the same number of years that
uranus takes to orbit the sun seahorses
are the only fish with a neck and the
only family of animals where the male
gives birth the word skia potus means
one has large enough feet to be used as
umbrellas powerful acids and snake
stomachs means that they will explode if
given alka-seltzer over the years the
British Royal Navy's fleet has included
HMS seagull HMS Keith's hms tour toys
HMS Wensley Dale and Hatem s cockchafer
Nigeria makes more movies every year
than the US Venezuela is Spanish for
little Venice despite their names white
rhinos and black rhinos are the same
color
feeding Canaries red peppers turns them
orange hummingbirds have 2,000 meals a
day and hibernate every night in 2007 a
bosnian called Amir waha Bhavik faked
his own death to see how many people
would go to his funeral only his mother
turned up Queen Elizabeth the first
often drank two Pines of strong beer for
breakfast in 1875 the king of Fiji
bought back measles from a state visit
to Australia and wiped out a quarter of
his own people in 2003 sick
monkeys were funded by the Arts Council
of England to see how long it would take
them to type out the works of
Shakespeare after six months they had
failed to produce a single word of
English broken the computer and used a
keyboard as a lavatory thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2